bonsoir Monsieur chaugard dit l'employé
Dans le travail était de ne jamais
oublier un visage
Henrich hogar avait 41 ans c'était un
homme riche et célibataire étrange voici
ce qu'un élu dans le petit cahier
d'exercices bleu
monsieur je suis un homme qui voit sans
se servir de ses yeux il l'a vu hurler
il a absolument incroyable
j'en respecte
c'est une information proprement
fantastique elle pourrait changer ma vie
quelque chose d'extraordinaire se
produisit tout à coup il vit à travers
sa peau comme au rayon X mais plus
précisément encore il vit tout désormais
henry était capable de gagner de
l'argent plus rapidement que n'importe
qui dans le monde
intéressant
[Musique]
il s'appelait riche au gars il est
important que les gens sachent ce qu'il
a fait pour l'humanité
[Rires]